In the US, the Pentagon announced...
...that 34 US troops were diagnosed with traumatic brain injuries...
...after the Iran missile strike in Iraq earlier this month.
In Puerto Rico, hundreds of people protest in a show of anger...
...over the discovery of millions of dollars in unused emergency aid...
...after the island was struck by a recent 6.4 magnitude earthquake.
Health officials in China confirmed 26 casualties...
...and more than 880 cases of the coronavirus, which has now spread to 10 countries.
China has placed 10 cities, totaling 30 million people,...
...under lockdown to try to contain the virus.
In Iraq, thousands of supporters of radical Iraqi cleric Muqtada al-Sadr gathered in Baghdad...
...to demand the removal of US troops amid growing anti-US sentiment.
Finally from Germany, six people are dead and several wounded...
...after a shootout in southwest Germany Friday.
Police arrested one suspect and believe the shooter knew several of the victims.